[Music]
good evening ladies and gentlemen my
name is National Master Ralph tan and
welcome to beginnner breakdown today
we're going to dive into the concept of
drawing combinations so to illustrate
let's take a look at this position
between green versus iin in
1966 so first things first what is is a
draw so a draw is when neither player
wins or lose so both players get a half
a point and the game is declared as a
draw so there are several types of ways
that a draw could be achieved first
being stalemate where one player cannot
move any of their pieces and it is
currently their turn so stalemate can be
claimed the second way is insufficient
material so if there's not enough
material on the board so for example if
it's just the two loone kings Checkmate
is not possible and in addition there's
cases where there could be a king versus
bishop and versus a king and that's not
enough material to Checkmate there's
also by agreement one player could offer
another player a draw and they could
accept it another way is three-fold
repetition or Perpetual check so if you
achieve the same position three times
then a draw can be claimed in addition
there is also the 50 move rule so if the
game continues on for 50 moves without a
single capture or pawn move then a draw
can be declared so let's dive into this
position here so the idea that we want
to try to go for when finding these
drawing combinations is that when
whenever we find ourselves losing or in
Hopeless positions we should never give
up we should try to find ways in order
to not lose here so in this position we
are black and if we evaluate the
material black has one to three pawns
white has one pawn and both sides have a
queen but unfortunately here white does
have this extra Rook so where so they
have a lot of material and the threats
for white are very scary they have
either Queen to G4 Checkmate or queen to
G6 followed up by Queen takes H6
Checkmate so for black we're going to
need to find a way to
avoid trying to lose here so what black
is going to try to do here is play this
move Queen to E1 check attacking the
king now this King on H1 has only one
square to go go to which is this G2
Square so as the King goes to G2 what we
can do here as black is place our Queen
on D2 with a check now black is excuse
me white has a choice to make so they
can't really go back to H1 otherwise
there are there is this queen to H2
Checkmate and if the king tries to go to
F1
then what we can do here as black is
just simply repeat by checking with
Queen to D1 check let's say the King
goes back to G2 we can play this move
Queen to D2 check
again now if the King goes to if the
king captures the pawn then what we can
do here as black is play this move Queen
to G2 check giving up our Queen and
after the uh King
takes excuse me wrong line so after the
king takes on G3 and there is this move
Queen to
D6 check and after The Rook captures Our
Queen then it is stalemate because the
black king has nowhere to go to and this
Pawn on G5 is completely pinned so it
can't move because the queen would be
attacking the king so no squares to go
to so let's try to give some of these
problems a try here so we are black in
this position it's between Porsche
versus LEL in
1964 black to move so we can see here
that black is a bit of a deficit in this
position so both sides have the queen
but if we count the pawns white has one
two three pawns and black has one Pawn
so if white is able to acheve achieve a
position where they can trade off their
Queen and trade off a pawn they'll be
left with two pass pawns which they can
promote and try to win the game what we
can also notice here is that black their
King on h8 has no squares to go to
because of the fact that this queen on
G6 is taking away the H7 G7 and G8
Square in addition Albert Pawn on D5
can't move at all because there's an
opposing Pawn in the way so it looks
like here that our only mobile piece is
this queen on D7 so we need to find a
way to maybe get rid of our mobile Queen
in order to achieve stalemate where we
can't play where we can't move any of
our
pieces so the move here in this position
is this queen to G D4 check inviting
white to capture Our Queen on G4 because
if so after the king takes on G4 then it
is stalemate the black king has nowhere
to go to and the black pawn can't move
forward now if white tries to avoid
capturing the queen let's say King to H6
saying that if you trade my queen if you
capture my queen then I can take back
and I should have an easy game with this
p with this pass Pawn running down the
board but in this case if the King goes
to H6 what we can do is simply slide Our
Queen to H4 with a check attacking the
king and White's only move is to play
Queen to H5 blocking the check now what
we can do here is black is play Queen to
F6 check and after white blocks what we
can can do is just simply repeat the
position three times and we can claim a
draw now let's say if the king tries to
go to F6 well we're going to follow the
same pattern here we're going to try to
give up our mobile Queen by playing this
move Queen to E6 check and if white
captures the queen then it is stalemate
we have no squares to go to to and if
the king simply just returns back where
it came from we can just repeat our move
of Queen to G4 check and we can
successfully get a draw as if they
repeat we will repeat it until we've
reach a position three times in a row
Perfect all right let's take a look at
this position between pause Mike and an
unknown player in 1995 and we are right
here in this position white to move so
white is at a bit of a deficit in this
position due to Black threats and
material black is up one whole Rook the
H1 Rook while we don't have a rook
though we do have a queen and a knight
for their Queen and Bishop here in
addition here we can also notice that
this bishop on C6 and the Queen on D5
are creating a battery so they're
controll rolling from the C6 to G2
diagonal and with this battery in mind
black is threatening to capture on G2
and essentially get a very strong attack
with ideas of if King to H4 maybe they
could try moving their Pawn or capturing
H3 so we have to be really careful here
as white so in the last two positions we
saw that we can try to get s state where
none of our pieces can move but I think
we have a little bit too much here as
white as we can move all of these pawns
we have the Knight and queen so we're
going to find another method in order to
achieve a draw
here so that move is Knight to F6 check
so with Knight to F6 check we are
attacking the king and we are attacking
the queen on D5 so a fork
and if the king ever moves away that is
a huge mistake as we can simply play
Queen to B8 check and we will have
Checkmate as the queen goes to d8 you
will capture the Queen the bishop blocks
the check and then we can capture the
bishop
checkmate so black cannot move their
King and if they try to move their King
to G6 then what we can do is just simply
scoop up the queen and the tables have
turned a little bit here in which I
think white has a much favorable
position now as they have a queen in
compensation for the bishop and Rook
here so that leaves black with one real
Choice here which is to capture the
Knight on F6 well if black captures the
Knight on F6 what we can do here as
white is capture the F7 point Pawn with
a check here attacking the king we
couldn't capture the pawn on F7 earlier
because there's this Pawn on
G7 so after Knight F6 Pawn takes F6
Queen takes F7 checking the king Black's
King can only go to one square which is
King to h8 and now after the King goes
to h8 what white can do here is play to
move Queen to f8 check and once black
returns to their original Square then
what we can do here is repeat the
position by playing Queen to F7 check so
we have essentially Perpetual check
never ending checks and the position
will be a draw very
soon all right how about we try this
position to tenko versus murel in
1961 and it is black to move here so
black is at a bit of a deficit as white
has a whole Rook against black so black
has three pawns white also has three
pawns and both sides have a queen but
left over is this Rook on
E6 so it's very hard for black to create
any progress here though you have a pass
Pawn these two pieces for white The Rook
on E6 and Queen on C8 do oh far and well
enough job to try to easily attack black
so there are threats with Queen takes A6
check followed up with support of The
Rook maybe coming to C6 after the King
goes to C3 many dangerous things
here and we can't really try ideas like
Queen to D1 check because there are
ideas where white can just play King to
F2 and I think they might just be pretty
much safe after let's say queen to D2
check King to G3 white has play now so
what we have to do here as black is find
a way to achieve a draw here and what we
can notice is that we have some pieces
that cannot move at all and that
includes these three pawns here there's
something in the way for these pawns to
try to move forward the pawn on G4 is in
the way the King on D3 is in the way and
the pawn on A5 is in the way in addition
our King on D3 can't move at all can't
move to E4 E3 or E2 because of this Rook
on E6 and likewise with C2 C3 and C4
because of this queen on C8 so it seems
to be here that our only real mobile
piece here for black is our Queen on D2
so we need to find a way to get rid of
our Queen in order to escape a loss here
so in the chat we have the move Queen to
C1 check beautiful move because if white
captures Our Queen on C1 then we have
achieved stalemate as the King has
nowhere to go to the queen covers C2 C3
C4 covers D2 and E3 alongside with this
Rook covering E4 and E2 so no squares
for our King to go to and our pawns
can't move and of course if white tries
to move the king then white will
actually be the one losing as we can
take their Queen on C8 creating a skewer
so attacking The Rook on E6 and also
indirectly attacking this Pawn on G4 so
once The Rook moves away we can scoop up
this pawn and we should have a very fine
game here for
black all right let's try this one so
this one's a pretty well-known drawing
combination we have pilnick versus rusi
in 1942 and it is white to move here so
it is very evident that white is in a
bit of a pickle as they only have one
Pawn versus Black's four Pawn pawns so
if black can try to trade off a pawn
they have three past pawns that can
promote into a queen and finish off the
game and both sides do have their Queens
here so what could white try to do in
order to not lose this position well
what we can notice here is that our King
is on H1 so it's in the very Corner
whenever a piece is in the corner it
typically has not a lot of squares to go
to so the king would have three squares
to go to but G1 is currently covered
because of this queen on E3 so we
technically have two squares for Albert
King to go to so G2 and H2 and in
addition we have a very mobile Queen on
fa it has a lot of directions that it
can go to so maybe we can try to
coordinate a way where we can set up
Black's pieces in which we would have no
legal
moves so what we can also notice here is
that the King on A7 and the Queen on E3
are on the same diagonal from A7 all the
way to G1 here so perfect in the chat we
have the move Queen to F2 creating a
skewer here so we are attacking the
queen and in addition we are indirectly
attacking the King on A7 and this is
also a pin because the queen can't move
otherwise the king would be in
danger so what black would have to do is
capture the queen on F2 and after the
black queen captures on F2 then white
has no legal squares to go to therefore
stalemate and if black tries to do
anything else let's say they tried to
escape the pin or try to push the pawn
then white would actually be winning in
this position as they can capture the
queen on E3 and essentially scoop up the
pawns soon and bring the king into
action all right we're looking good here
so white to move we have Howards versus
Pavey in
1951 so as we evaluate this position
white has one two three
four so looks like we do have a question
regarding the last puzzle why couldn't
the queen move to B3 well the queen
can't move to B3 because there is this
pin alongside this diagonal from F2 to
A7 so Black's best choice is just to
capture the queen but that would end in
the
stalemate all right back to this so
white has one two three four pawns black
has one two three four five six pawns so
black is up two pawns but it looks like
we have a queen for their Rook on A3 so
it looks like we are up to exchange up a
lot of good material but unfortunately
black does have a tactic against us and
it is the skewer along the third rank so
that means if we move our King the queen
will be lost and we can't move our Queen
because there is this pin alongside this
King on H3 the king would be under
attack and in addition this Rook on A3
is supported by this B4 Pawn so
unfortunately for us we can't do any
measures of capturing The Rook on A3
because black will just just capture
back and they'll soon just run down the
board and
promote so it looks like we are in very
big trouble here as white but we can
find a move that can let us
Escape inevitable lost here so in the
chat we have this wonderful move King to
H4 a very Sly move because if black
captures Our Queen on F3 which is
probably the best
move then we have stalemate in this
position our pawns cannot move because
there is a piece in the way and in
addition our King on H4 has nowhere to
go to because the pawn on F5 is guarding
G4 the pawn on G6 is guarding H5 and our
and The Rook on F3 is guarding G3 and H3
so we have no squares to go to therefore
stale mate and if black tries to do
anything else let's say pushing the pawn
to B3 then I think white can just
deliver a check with F4 maybe after the
king moves away we can play a move like
Queen to C1 essentially just trying to
stop black promoting their Pawn on the B
file very
nice all right how about we give this
puzzle a go so we have have gise versus
swen in
1961 and it is white Tove here so black
there are a lot of black pieces on the
board here so if we evaluate white has
two pawns black has one two three four
five pawns so they are up three pawns
both sides have a queen and it looks
like black has the better deal of the
exchange for two pieces for for a rook
here and we can also notice that we are
in some big trouble here as white they
have a Pawn on H2 ready to promote but
luckily for us we do have our King on H1
preventing the pawn from promoting and
they have two pass pawns alongside the a
file ready to promote and there is this
immediate Queen to G1 Checkmate idea
here so it looks like we can't really
try to go for a win in this position so
what we want to try to do is essentially
find a way
to achieve a draw here and what we can
notice is that we have three non-mobile
pieces so our King on H1 can't move at
all this Pawn on H2 is protected by the
bishop and the Queen on G5 is covering
G2 and G1 so no squares for the king and
these two pawns C4 4 and D5 cannot move
because there are pieces in the way so
for the C Pawn this Knight on C5 and for
the D Pawn this bishop on D6 so it looks
like here our two mobile pieces are our
Queen and Rook so they have plenty
plenty of squares to go to so what we
need to do here as white is maybe find a
way to get rid of our mobile p
but in which order is the correct way
and how could we force them to try to
take our
material otherwise if given a chance
they will play Queen to G1 check
me so what we're going to do here in
this position is capture this Pawn on H7
with a check so forcing black to react
they have no squares to go to for their
King this besides capturing our rook and
once they capture our Rook on H7 what we
can do here as white is also give black
Our Queen by playing Queen to h8 track
forcing black to capture Our Queen on h8
and then we have successfully achieved
stalemate as we have no squares to go to
and I would also like to comment another
funny cute move inste of Queen to h8 is
also this move Queen to G8 check so
essentially saying the same idea cuz if
the king takes then it's stalemate but
let's just say if black really wants to
push for the win and sees that if we
capture the queen it would be stalemate
and if they try to play this move King
H6 then the tables have turned Queen to
h8 Checkmate so plaque has all this
material but yet they lose
so a nice little addition to this puzzle
here all right on to the next one all
right so we are white in this position
and it looks like we are in a different
stage of Chess we are in the middle game
here so a lot more pieces than the
previous puzzles we have looked at where
we are in the end game there are few
pieces and fewer Mobility around this
position here so white to move we have
schwier versus dely in
1924 and how could we achieve a draw
here in this position as white and the
reason why white wants to achieve a draw
is because of the fact that black has a
lot of material they do have a bit of a
nuisance on D3 in which if we try to
capture we're going to be left with some
weaknesses double isolated pawns and
they are easy to Target in attack
and if we just count material then both
sides have a rook both sides have a
queen both sides both sides have a minor
piece but black does have this extra
minor piece sitting on C8 and we could
also count the pawns white has 1 2 3
four five six seven pawns and black has
1 two 3 4 5 six seven pawns as well so
white is just playing out down a whole
Keys here so what could we do here in
the middle game to try to achieve a draw
here so perfect in the chat we have the
suggestion Knight to G5 a very very
clean move essentially saying we're
trying to Checkmate you on H7 so if
you're careless let's say you try to
take my Pawn on C2 then what I will do
is just capture the pawn on H7 Checkmate
as it's supported by the Knight on G5 so
black does not want to do that let's say
they just capture the Knight on G5 well
if they capture a knight on G5 we can
just capture back on G5 with a check
forcing the king to run to the corner h8
and what we can do is perform Perpetual
checks so NeverEnding checks we can play
Queen Queen to F6 check and after the
King goes to G8 then we can return to
Queen G5 check and we will just repeat
this position two more CH two more times
and then we will achieve a draw now we
do have this suggestion after Pawn takes
king h8 queen to F6 King G8 maybe
there's this idea
of Rook to
E4 but the problem with Rook to E4 is
that we do have a nice idea of playing
Rook to G4 threatening Checkmate but I
believe here black may play something
like Pawn to E5 just uncovering this
bishop to guard this G4 square and we
can't really perform Checkmate here and
we can't really reroute our rook in time
let's say if we try Rook H4 maybe black
will just offer a proposal of a trade
with the queens and we'll be losing here
as white and there's nothing else that
black can do after Knight to G5 they
could possibly delay it let's say Pawn
to H6 but we can just capture on H6
after they capture back we can just move
our Queen alongside H5 and G5 performing
Perpetual check and in
addition here if black TR some sort of
sneaky move like Bishop takes H2 we have
to be really careful we should not
capture this bishop on H2 because if we
do they will simply take back and once
we take back they'll just be up a piece
so the correct move here would be a move
like King to
H1 and then they would have to take and
then we can perform once again our
Perpetual checks
and we do also have a suggestion after
Knight G5 what about Rook to d8 here
well the problem with Rook to Da is that
I think I can just capture on H7 here
after the King goes to
f8 what I can do is maybe play Queen to
h8 check King to
D7 and I might have some idea ideas
where I can maybe capture this Pawn on
E6 and if Pawn takes then there is
Perpetual here I believe and if Bishop
takes maybe Rook takes if Pawn takes
there's some sneaky ideas of Perpetual
and if King takes there might be some
dangerous plans with Rook to E1 check
here
so if this yeah so after Knight two G5
whoops Knight to G5 Pawn takes we can
deliver
Perpetual here and let me just turn on
the engine and see what they say after
Rook d8 huh it looks like black is still
a little bit better here so a move like
Knight E4 hm interesting interesting but
that's essentially the try and gist for
Knight to G5 here all right let's take a
look at another one here so we have an
endgame we have black to move we have
nikoleski versus tonov in
1966 and it is black to move and we want
to try to get a draw here so the reason
why we want to get a draw is because of
the placements of
the opponent of the Kings here so
White's King is very active they are
ready to go behind our pawns and
essentially try to capture them and our
pawns are kind of stuck here we can't
make any real advancements because
there's just Pawns in the way
here so what should we try to do here as
black yeah so essentially in the last
puzzle it's a bit
unclear after Rook
d8 there might be some ideas where black
may be able to
hold so what could black do here in this
position so we have this idea in chat
where we can try to stalemate ourselves
on A5 so we want to try get to this A5
Square so let's try King B6 well if King
to B6 looks like I can just play King to
D6 kind of putting you in a little bit
of Zug Swang because if you move your
king then the pawn Falls but luckily for
us we have this move King to A5
essentially saying you can have my Pawn
on C5 but if you capture it it will be
stalemate as we have no squares to go to
to our pawns can't move as there's
pieces in the way and our King on
A5 can't move at all so it can't go to
B6 because of the C5 King can't go to B5
because of the king and pawn and it
can't go to A4 because of this B3 Pawn
so no squares to go to and no matter how
hard white tries here we can just dance
our King to B6 and A5 so for example
let's say King to A5 let's say they hold
on a little bit they play to move King
to D5 we can just play King B6 and
essentially try to aim for a repeating
position and in addition after King F A5
if the king tries to go to C6 or C7 it's
essentially stalemate as well with black
having no pieces that can move all right
right we are looking good how about we
give this one a try so we have white to
move we have Matt lovic versus bovic in
1970 and it is white to move here now
white wants to try to achieve a draw
here because of the fact that they are
down a pawn so white has two pawns black
has three pawns and both sides have
their queen and the coordination of
their pieces so their King is on the
very first
rank has almost no squares to go to and
in the end game the king is really
important and you should try to activate
the king as much as you can and in
addition yeah so can't move any of our
pawns King has no squares to go to so
it's best for white to try to achieve a
draw as black will try to find a way to
scoop up these pawns and essentially
create a new
Queen so what we can do here as white
perfect we have this move Queen to D3
cheack so we are attacking the queen on
D6 and we are attacking the king at F3
at the same time so we're creating a
fork so if the black king tries to move
then that just is a bad move for black
as we can capture the queen and then
we'll be the ones scooping up the pawns
and winning the game and if the black
queen tries to capture Our Queen then
what we successfully done here is
created stalemate as white has no no
pieces that can move the pawns have
something in the way of them from moving
and our King on E1 has no squares to go
to as the queen on D3 covers D2 and D1
and also covers F1 and E2 and the King
on F3 covering the F2 Square so we've
turned this losing position into a draw
here all right we are looking
good all right we have black to move we
have delling versus Schultz in
1982 here and it is black to move so it
looks a little bit more complicated as
we have a few more mobile pieces than we
would have here so through evaluating
here black has two pawns and a queen and
black has three pawns and a queen and
Rook so looks like white is up a whole
rook and pawn so they're looking good
material-wise and there are some very
scary threats that white has on black
essentially the this Rook coming to h8
checkm so black needs to basically find
a way out of this losing position and
find a way to achieve a draw so they
don't
lose so what could we do here as
black so we have the suggestion of
putting our Queen to H1 check so we are
voluntarily giving up our mobile pieces
so our mobile pieces here are a Pawn on
G3 as it can capture the pawn on F2 and
our Queen with its many squares that it
can go to so we got to get rid of these
two pieces and by doing that we will
play Queen to H1 check after the king
takes what we can do here as black is
invite them to C capture our Pawn
because if they capture our Pawn then we
successfully achieve stalemate because
our King has nowhere to go to because of
the fact that the queen and Rook are
taking away the squares of the king and
the queen is preventing this Pawn on F7
from
moving now if black tries excuse me if
white tries to play King G1 still
stalemate and if they try to move out
the way what we can do is promote after
the king moves then we can just place
our Queen right in front of the king
forcing white to capture and as they
capture either with the pawn or with the
King then we've successfully achieve
stalemate here so what if black tries
to excuse me if white tries to just
capture the G3 Pawn so simply ignoring
the Queen and trying to find a Checkmate
here with Rook to h8 well what we can do
here is offer our Queen up so Queen to
G2 check if the white king takes then it
is stalemate if the king moves to H4 and
we can just simply place our Queen right
in front of the qu king queen to G4
check and after the king takes then it
is
stalemate and if the king tries to run
away to F4 what we can try here is a
move like Queen to F3 check if King
takes
stalemate if the King goes to G5 we can
force the queen to go to G4 and once
they captured back it is
stalemate and if black if white
continues to ignore then we can just
play Queen to D5 track just keep
offering our Queen and of course if
white tries to avoid capturing the queen
we can just repeat the position and then
we can still achieve our drawing idea
here all right so that was a bit of a
long one but I think we got a good gist
of how we can well the pattern of
finding stalemate is giving up a lot of
our mobile
pieces all right how about we try this
puzzle here black to move we have ref
shelar versus seure in
1983 and there we are in the endgame
stage and there are a lot of pieces here
so if we evaluate black has one two
three four five pawns white also has
Five Pawns as well both sides have a
queen both sides have a rook both but
for white they have this extra Knight on
F5 so we are at a deficit material wise
and we are pretty much losing this
position because of threats where white
just simply simplify the material get
rid of all our Firepower and there's
threats where white could capture the D6
Pawn with either the queen or Knight and
in addition they could try to activate
their rook and come to B7 and try to
achieve some sort of initiative here so
what could we do here as black to
basically avoid ourselves from
losing okay
so black can play this move Rook to C1
check so would Rook to C1 check after
The Rook captures our Rook instead of
capturing back on C1 what we can do is
actually capture this queen on B8
because of the fact that the Rook on B1
is no longer there protecting the queen
on
B8 so for example if white were to move
and then we were to capture the queen
their Rook would be there to capture
back
so it looks like white can't capture The
Rook but what happens if they let's say
do move away to King to G2 well what we
can do here is play this move Queen to
C2 check and basically the idea is that
we are offering we are attacking the
king and soon we'll be offering a way to
give up our pieces in order to achieve
stalemate so we have a question do we
have any winning chances after Queen
takes ba8 though that looks like
unpleasant almost well after Queen takes
ba8 I think for the most part we aren't
necessarily winning because I believe
white can at most just bring their Rook
to F1 and kind of just dance around
along F2 so for for example let's just
say I do this check King there and if I
try to do some sort of breakthrough then
white could just dance around with their
pieces and there isn't really too many
ways for white to try to win here as our
Queen has a lot of squares to go to and
try to get some sort of way too
Perpetual
check but the idea here is that after
the King goes to G2 Queen to C2 check
after King to G3 what we can play is
this move Rook to G1 check so if the
Rook captures our Rook we can now offer
our Queen up by playing Queen to H2
check forcing white to capture Our Queen
and then we've successfully achieved
stalemate as there are no squares for
our King to go to this Pawn on H5 is
covering the G6 Square the Knight on F5
is covering the G7 square and the Queen
on B8 is covering G8 and h8 squares for
our King and of course white doesn't
want to move their King away from check
otherwise there is sneaky little
checkmate with Queen to G2 here and the
same thing with King to H3 what we can
try to do here is play Rook to H1 if
they capture then we could play Queen to
G2 forcing white to capture us then we
would achieve
stalemate and if they can't move to G3
otherwise there is Queen to H2
Checkmate and it's also a good thing to
point out that we don't really have any
ideas of capturing this Rook on B1 with
either our Rook or queen because of the
fact that their Knight and queen will
deliver Checkmate so for example if we
try to play Rook takes B1 then we have
this move Queen to A7 check attacking
the King on H7 forcing the king to go to
G8 or uh h8 or G8 then we can deliver as
white Checkmate on
G7 so that is the solution to this
drawing combination here so now what I
have for you guys is some pretty cool
facts
regarding stalemates and draws here so
the first thing I have is the shortest
known stalemate composed by Sam Lloyd
who is a chess player chess composer
puzzle author and a recreational
mathematician and at the very start of
the game where all the pieces are set up
lots of moves you can achieve stalemate
in 10 moves so a pretty cool thing
to uh look at but I don't suggest we try
this at home so in 10 moves we can
achieve stalemate so white opens up the
game with E3 Pawn to
A5 Queen to H5 so we're breaking opening
principles Rook to A6 Queen takes A5
Pawn to H5 Queen takes C7 Rook a to H6
Pawn to H4 Pawn to F7 uh excuse me pawn
to F6 Queen takes D7 check King to F7
Queen takes B7 Queen to D3 Queen takes
B8 Queen to H7 Queen takes C8 and after
King to G6 white can deliver stalemate
with the move Queen to E6 as all of
these pieces of black are pretty much
trapped they can't move anywhere this
Pawn on F6 is pinned can't move
otherwise the queen would be attacking
the king and we have our Queen covering
F7 F5 and our Pawn on H4 covering the G5
Square so this is the shortest known
stalemate in 10
moves well there is more to that we have
the shortest stalemate with all the
pieces so no captures and this time it
is in 12 moves and it is composed by
Charles H wheeler so white opens up with
Pawn to D4 Pawn to D6 Queen to D2 Pawn
to E5
A4 E4 Queen to F4 Pawn to f F5 H3 Bishop
to E7 Queen to H2 Bishop to E6 Rook to
A3 Pawn to C5 Rook to G3 so basically
enclosing White's Queen here Queen to A5
check Knight to D2 so self-pinning
Bishop to H4 Pawn to F3 so another self
pin Bishop to B3 we have Pawn to D5
E3 C4 and the final move to achieve
stalemate is this move Pawn to F4 and
white has no legal moves at all Knight
can't move because of this pin Rook
can't move because of this pin and all
our other pieces can't move because
there is another piece in the way from
allowing us to move so pretty cool facts
here and there is one more pretty nice
stalemate we can achieve double
stalemate and this time it is in 18
moves and it is composed or discovered
by Enzo
Mana so Pawn to C4 Pawn to D5 Queen to
B3 we have Bishop to H3 G takes H3 Pawn
to F5 Queen takes B7 King to F7 Queen
takes A7 King to G6 Pawn to F3 Pawn to
C5 Queen takes E7 Rook takes A2 King F2
Rook takes B2 Queen takes G7 check King
to H5 Queen takes G8 Rook takes B1 Rook
takes B1 King to H4 Queen takes h8 Pawn
to H5 Queen to H6 Bishop takes H6 Rook
takes B8 Bishop to E3 check D takes E3
Queen takes B8 King to G2 Queen to F4 e
takes F4 Pawn to
D4 and then we have this move Bishop to
E3 and after black captures on E3 we
have a essentially have we essentially
have double stalemate as in this case it
is white to move white has absolutely no
squares or no pieces to move so these
pawns can't move the the bishop Knight
and Rook can't move because there's
pieces in the way and our King has no
squares to go to as the pawn on E3
covers F2 and the King on H4 covers G3
now if it were black to move then they
would be in stalemate as well because
they can't move any of their pawns
because there's pieces in the way and in
addition their King can't move because
white covers these squares Pawn on H2
Pawn on F3 or H3 and the pawn on F4 so
double check mate so some pretty cool
facts uh knowing the shortest unique
possible stamates and essentially the
idea with drawing combinations is that
we should never give up though we are in
losing or hopeless positions we should
try to find ways in order
to create stalemates perpetuals or
achieve a way to get a draw rather than
losing so that is beginner's breakdown
my name is National Master Ralph tan and
I thank you for your
time
[Music]
he